I'm Stuart Varney I'm Martha McCallum
I'm Jason Chaffetz and this is the Fox
News Rundown
Wednesday
January 25th 2023
I'm Dave Anthony
former vice president Pence is now part
of the classified document drama
materials found at his home as special
counsels investigate the Trump and Biden
discoveries neither one of them is going
to result in criminal charges so I mean
how in the world do you prosecute former
president Trump and not prosecute
current president bye I'm Dana Perino
Ukraine is putting up its best fight
against a reinvigorated assault from
Russian forces but do they have the
Firepower and resources to persist we're
almost a year into the War I get that we
needed to ramp up somewhat but I think
history will look poorly on Biden at how
slowly he's acted here in trying to get
the ukrainians what they need and I'm
Tommy lahren I've got the final word on
the Fox News rundown
It's a drama that keeps unfolding
classified documents found where they
shouldn't
first former president Trump who's being
investigated by a special counsel over
materials the FBI seized from his
Florida Mar-A-Lago Resort last year then
came the discovery we learned about this
month President Biden had some documents
in an old office from his time as vice
president then more classified materials
were found and then more and even more
it is Wilmington Delaware residents some
from his Senate days too now a different
justice department special counsel is
investigating him something bad is going
on here and this is of the utmost
importance for our national security
Republican Congressman James Comer is
also investigating as chairman of the
house oversight committee we formally
sent requests to the Secret Service
about any communication or documents
that would give us an idea of who
actually had access to that house
President Biden keeps saying he takes
classified documents seriously and is
cooperating adding last week it bugs him
the media keeps asking him about it
we're fully cooperating looking forward
to getting this resolved quickly I think
you're going to find there's nothing
there I have no regrets I'm following
what the lawyers have told me they want
me to do it's exactly what we're doing
there's no there there now yet another
ex-vice President says he found
documents that have been turned over to
the FBI at his home in Indiana Mike
Pence disclosed that just yesterday it's
a big deal for any of us that we're on
committees in Congress that handle
classified documents Trey Gowdy is a
Republican and former congressman from
South Carolina who hosts his own Fox
podcast and also has a new book out this
week which we'll talk about shortly to
say that we would never leave the room
with classified documents is a gross
understatement it wasn't an option we
wouldn't have done it had it been an
option even when you took notes your
personal notes on classified documents
the note stayed in the skiff so for
those those of us that served on house
Intel or ethics were Judiciary and dealt
with classified documents we're
wondering how in the world did these
documents get from where they were
supposed to be to a private residence or
a beach house or a locked room in
Florida if you get classified documents
in the course of your duties as
president or vice president who's
bringing them to you who's making sure
that you are returning them not at the
end of your tenure but at the end of the
day it is befuddling to me how
classified information can just be
unaccounted for for decades so a lot has
been made especially by Republicans that
President Biden called former president
Trump you know Reckless irresponsible
for having all those documents to this
property that the FBI seized and now
he's dealing with his own and he says he
has no regrets so the problem and and
you dealt with this in Congress you have
of Republicans reacting Democrats
reacting are they just defending their
own team and going after the other team
is anyone looking at this fairly is
there way too I I just you know what I
mean there's one worse than the other
Trump or Biden I think you put your
finger on maybe why I left uh fairness
is really not a virtue in the modern
political environment it's a tremendous
virtue in a courtroom but in politics we
have a tendency to defend our friends
and criticize our perceived opponents
I'm not you know sophisticated enough as
a thinker to have two different
standards I'd like to have one standard
if it's wrong for my opponents to do it
now that doesn't minimize they're always
distinctions in cases yeah whether the
documents were kept in a pool room or a
garage or a home office yeah that is a
factual distinction it's just a
distinction that doesn't make a
difference well the difference that
people point out especially Democrats is
former president Trump did not give back
the documents that that that he claimed
his lawyers had claimed he did and the
FBI went in and found more after the the
Trump team had said we'd cooperated the
president President Biden says look I've
been cooperating all along we found them
we handed them over and we said come on
and look for more you know president
Trump I think to the extent that he's in
legal Jeopardy it is for his response
all right will there need be no response
if you're not asked so what the media
says is different is a separate crime it
is obstruction it is false statement to
the FBI through your lawyers but if the
FBI never asked you any questions how in
the world can you possibly make a false
statement to them that does not that
does not eliminate the other two
statutes are you possessing property
that's not yours and are you possessing
mishandling classified information
others have gotten in trouble for that
right legally there are people that have
been prosecuted under the gross
negligence I think what the department
minute again trying to be fair even
though there's not like a huge appetite
for that I think the department would
tell you we are looking to see whether
someone benefited from it it's not
simply the negligence okay which is why
it matters what documents were taken by
former president Trump and current
President Biden because what was taken
may lead you to a motive and then you
can determine whether there was any
benefit claimed okay all right so two
different special counsels doing two
different investigations under the same
umbrella
which one do you think is has a harder
job
um I actually think they both have
pretty easy jobs really because because
neither one of them is going to result
in criminal charges so I mean how in the
world do you prosecute former president
Trump and not prosecute current
president right what if obstruction is
an allegation in one case but not the
other then I am sure president Trump's
supporters would say you know what it is
really difficult to give misleading or
false information to the FBI when they
never ask okay they're still getting
consent to search for President Biden
which means the president can say I give
you consent to search this room but not
that room they didn't towards the end
afford that privilege to former
president Trump they used a subpoena and
then they executed a search warrant I
would be curious I don't know and I hate
speculating but I'd be curious if there
were a full-blown search of all of
President Biden's resonances whether we
would find more your time in Congress
you you like you did four terms you
wrote in your new book which is again
the start Stay or Leave the art of
decision making it's out this week you
wrote that you were there too long like
you wanted to leave after your third
term you you wrote a letter that you
were readying that you were not going to
run again for term four but you ran
again yeah friendship that you have to
know what your weaknesses are in life
and and I have a bunch of them but
friendship has always been a weakness of
mine Tim Scott was my closest friend in
Congress he asked me to stay for good
and legitimate reasons um Senator South
Carolina you guys became good friends uh
he will preach my funeral uh so long as
he's not responsible for my funeral he
will he will appreciate yes but Tim you
know South Carolina has a a rich
provocative history as it relates to
race and he was going to be on the
ballot Statewide for his own full
six-year term and he said let's do it
together I didn't want to run but when
he talked me into running he said let's
do it together and I'll never ask you to
stay again and he never asked me to stay
again so your book's the art of decision
making
you made a decision you didn't want to
do but as I discussed in the book this
is where leaving is hard you love your
co-workers but you don't love your job
yeah so the way I look at it it was two
years too long in a job that was the
cost the benefit is relationships that I
will keep for the rest of my life so was
it worth it I don't know but also you
can't one thing you cannot do anything
about is what has already happened so I
left after eight years instead of after
six years two years is at the right
price to pay for lifelong friendships
probably yes you were a federal
prosecutor years before you were in
Congress you had wrote In the book it
was your dream job was but you got sick
of it it was it became like I guess as
you wrote you didn't get a lot of great
cases uh the federal system is not where
you need to be if you want to prosecute
violent crime yeah you need to be in the
state system so I left my dream job
because I wanted to prosecute homicide
and assault and robberies and burglaries
and I did that for 10 years and then you
know also write about when the when the
price you pay for even doing something
you love is too much and for me the
price was you know from a faith
standpoint what I grew up being told and
what I was listening to on Sunday
mornings was not consistent with what I
was seeing in crime scene photos well I
know what you wrote In the book but why
what was it were you questioning
why God could because people say that
all the time how can God let children be
molested right why could God let these
crimes you've seen things that none of
us have seen you have an elderly couple
they've worked hard their entire lives
they've done nothing wrong and someone
comes into their house with a hammer and
beats them to death and then rapes her
post-mortem yeah I think it's
appropriate to say God why
he wrote that your first big case
and this is why closing argument was
early in the in your book you wrote the
ending of your trial first yes I do it
with speeches I do it with my Sunday
night television show people don't
remember everything some people argue
they remember what they hear first some
people argue what they hear Last nobody
argues what you hear in the middle so if
the closing argument is the most
important part of a trial or speech then
why not kind of map that out and see
what gets you there
when you made your choices you talk
about starting you talk about staying
and then and then leaving what's the
hardest thing for you if you have a job
you like staying or leaving what's
harder I think staying is harder because
it lacks the excitement of something new
and fresh and we kind of condition our
minds to think that the grass is greener
somewhere else and so what I caution
people in the book is make sure what
you're leaving doesn't follow behind you
if if you're not happy with something
about yourself
then changing where you work is not
going to fix that I don't think you're
in the media now you wrote In the book
and the that you didn't the media was
one of the worst things you dealt with
when you were in Congress now you are
the media yeah have you had a hard time
with that
uh I try to be fair uh on my show I
think the best argument should win so
what I do on my show I've had people
that I don't agree with anything comes
out of their mouth but I'm going to give
you five minutes and then the viewer can
make up his or her mind who has the more
compelling case look when you
cross-examined people in murder cases
disagreeing on whether the tax rate
should be 36 or 34 percent just doesn't
seem that significant start Stay or
Leave the art of decision making it's
the new book that is just out this week
for former Congressman Trey Gowdy you
can watch him Sunday night in America on
Fox News Channel also the Trey Gowdy
podcast right here on our Fox News
podcast Network Congressman thanks very
much for joining us thank you for having
me and thank you for reading the book
[Music]
this is Tommy lahren with your Fox News
commentary coming up
it's been nearly a year since Russia
began its invasion of Ukraine President
Vladimir Putin's anticipated quick
Victory which military analysts
predicted worldwide never took place
thanks to the resilience and
perseverance of the Ukrainian people and
their military however in recent weeks
we are seeing a shift in Tides Russia
has been claiming advances in both the
Eastern and Southern regions of Ukraine
threatening to seize important strategic
footholds as Russia has shaken up its
strategy with a newly appointed
Commander president zielinski has
continued to stress the need for heavy
Weaponry like modern battle tanks to
fight off what experts anticipate to be
a reinvigorated ground offensive from
Russian forces we have to speed up time
must become our common weapon just like
air defense and artillery armored
vehicles and tanks which we are
negotiating about with you and which
actually will make the victory Western
allies have met many of zelenski's calls
with the U.S announcing plans to send
hundreds of armored vehicles and Rockets
and Britain pledging to send 14
Challenger tanks to Ukraine and UK prime
minister Boris Johnson reiterated his
support for Ukraine while visiting Kiev
this past Sunday saying this the UK will
be sticking by Ukraine for as long as it
takes you are going to win and you're
going to get all the Russians out of
your country but we will be there for
the long term the war in Ukraine has
raised on since February of 2022 and
while President zielinski and his people
have projected strength and competency
the winter is bringing fresh
difficulties for ukrainians defending
against Russia's new war tactics and
immense military power this summer or
maybe this spring we're going to see a
significant counter offensive from
Ukraine Michael Allen is founder and
managing director of Beacon Global
strategies LLC and former Special
Assistant for National Security to
President George W bush they have been
preparing and stockpiling weapons and
other types of artillery in anticipation
of this they have said they're not even
using all of their equipment for the
little ongoing battles and skirmishes
that are happening today because they're
trying to amass it for a bigger run both
in the East called The Don Bassett in
the South as well
this week on America's Newsroom you said
that Ukraine could go on the offensive
even more and we've been watching this
long drawn out debate of Germany being
willing to send their leopard two tanks
how did that end up
and what could Ukraine do with those
so you're you know you're exactly right
we have been trying to figure out we
NATO what the ukrainians would need for
a big counter-offensive and I think all
military experts have settled on they
need a more armor they need armored
vehicles they need tanks and the ones
that American strategists believe are
best suited for the terrain in Ukraine
or the German Leopard tanks ours are
terrific as well of course but I think
it's harder logistically of course to
get them there the types of fuel it uses
and how often it needs to be refueled
and so just about everyone in NATO I
think except for Germany has been on
board with this and at different times
we thought Germany would be just okay
with at least other countries that they
had previously sold their leopard tanks
to you know they have to agree by
contract to agree that they could be
transferred to Ukraine but you know last
week we suffered a big defeat
diplomatically I think Divine
Administration failed to convince
Germany how important this was and
they've put on pressure all weekend long
and I think the Germans are getting
close at least to okay others to send
their tanks and they may be on the verge
of agreeing to send some of their own so
that's good news if that happens because
of course we need our allies to step up
it can't be only the United States
that's out here financing and
transferring equipment we need a big
gigantic economy like the Germans to
step up and I hope they're about to do
that does Germany have good reason to be
hesitant
I don't think so you know they look back
on their history and they have said
things just morally we want to be in the
middle of the pack we don't want to be
seen as having German tanks rolling
towards Russia again again trying to
think of The Echoes of World War II but
I think that's falling on a lot of deaf
ears people are saying listen your
obligations now are for the peace and
security of the world clearly here
Russia is the aggressor and what you
need to do as a leader in Europe and a
participant in NATO is send tanks or
send anything that you have that's
particularly good for the battlefield
and get it in the game and I think
they've been dragging their feet and
it's really raised a lot of questions
about whose side do you want after all
are you just trying to wait to the end
of the war so you can have terrific
economic relations with Russia all over
again you know oil and gas Etc but we're
dragging them there and I hope we can
get them there any moment now Boris
Johnson the former prime minister of the
UK said the sooner we can help Ukraine
to Victory the sooner their suffering
will be over but it feels to me like the
Russians they just keep going they they
have lost a lot of people we know that
um but they're bringing more conscripts
in
and they continue to fight as people
forced to fight will fight so what about
the Russian positioning right now what
are they thinking so I think Putin
believes he still has cards to play
You're right he's continuing to press
people into military service their
reports in rural areas where they
literally go grab people and put them on
a bus and send them to the front lines
these are not well-trained troops when
they finally get to Ukraine and enter
the battle but it is still I think
exhausting for the ukrainians to have to
continue to try and kill or defeat waves
of new soldiers coming from Russia and
so I think it would be wrong of me to
say it's not having any effect I think
it is having some effect on the
ukrainians and their ability to cope
with
this incredible mass of Russian soldiers
come at them all the time I think it
will help complicate what the ukrainians
are trying to do but you're right it's
2023 this is the pivotal year in the
conflict they need to make progress
especially in the South so that we can
begin to look to a day where we won't
need so much U.S support where we they
won't need so much NATO support so that
we the United States can start looking
toward Asia so that Taiwan can be
sufficiently funded and armed to deter
China from taking Taiwan that's in our
national interest as well so we have a
lot going on right now and a lot of arms
that we need to transfer to different
allies you and I both worked for
President George W bush and of course
there was a ton of foreign policy
challenges at the time one of the things
that he would always make sure to do was
to say we need to explain to the
American people why this matters and so
there were big speeches and but even
smaller speeches and interviews and a
constant explanation because he knew
that it was going to be a long
generational war against ideological
enemies what I don't think you get from
the Biden administration at all is a
drum beat for them to explain to the
American people why this matters and
there's about to be some budget fights
and there are going to be some questions
about money that is being spent on
defense overall and funds being sent to
Ukraine
do you think the Biden Administration
recognizes that it has not communicated
well enough to the American people and
do you think that will change
I think the president has done a
terrible job of explaining the stakes to
the American people he very rarely
engages on this issue and even those of
us that are Republicans that are pretty
skeptical of President Biden know that
the American people need to hear from
the commander-in-chief about what our
national interests are he at least needs
to try and make the case he hasn't done
so I don't know if it's because he has
too much else going on or he's just
exhausted but he has not made the
Strategic Communications case for why
this is so incredibly important so it
would be incredibly helpful if President
Biden made this strategic case and got
out there and explained the U.S national
interest it does feel that Russia is
just so vicious in attacking civilians
and the world response is dismay
but it feels like the West gives Ukraine
what it needs but long after they have
already said that they need it
so this week it's tanks what are they
going to need in the near future that we
can anticipate
I think it's going to be an Air Force
and they have been asking for that since
the Russians invaded we've been lucky
frankly that the Russians have not
figured out a way to establish air
superiority over Ukraine and I don't
think we're going to be able to have a
modern fighting force for Ukraine to be
able to repel a neighbor like Russia
unless they have f-16s or if it's not
f-16s then it's the Swedish fighter and
you're exactly right I think the Biden
Administration has been overly cautious
all along they failed to deter Russia
from invading Ukraine in the first place
and they seem to really draw out the
decision-making process first on
howitzers and then later on certain
sophisticated artillery and now finally
tanks is having its day today I mean
we're almost a year into the War I get
that we needed to ramp up somewhat but I
think history will look poorly on Biden
at how slowly he's acted here in trying
to get the ukrainians what they need and
of course it's because it's in our
national interest I don't want to do or
get involved in disputes around the
world that aren't in the U.S national
interest I think this one is for the
reasons we've discussed and I think
Biden should have stepped this up long
ago
talk about one other thing you have been
involved in a project it's a book and
let me tell you this book that's coming
it is a big one and an important one I
read through some of it today it is
called handoff the foreign policy George
W bush passed to Barack Obama
why now what is the project and what
might we learn from picking this up and
looking through it
well the vision of President Bush was to
have the best transition in the history
of the country for us to update the
Obama people in 2009 as they came into a
very difficult foreign policy situation
to have the best of what the bush White
House had put together and performed on
for the previous eight years so we all
wrote memorandum they were highly
classified memorandum mine was on Iran
North Korea and other nuclear matters
others did things on Russia in Ukraine
and or China and so it is a wonderful
snapshot in time these classified memos
have been largely Declassified the
president's Second National Security
adviser Steve Hadley had us all write a
bit of an update an update essay to say
how did Bush do now that we have the
distance of you know over 12 years of
looking backwards and so I think for
people that really like foreign policy
and really like history it's a terrific
snapshot where did things end in January
2009 when Bush handed it over to
President Obama and how have these
issues evolved and we only need to look
at the Russia chapter to see that
President Bush regrets that he was not
able to get the relationship with Russia
on a firmer footing instead I think
Putin showed his true colors certainly
by 2008 when he invaded Georgia and
later under President Obama he invaded
Ukraine in 2014 for the first time so I
think I put all of these events in
perspective and for that I think it's
just a gift to History Michael Allen it
is always good to talk to you thank you
for being part of our show thank you
foreign
[Music]
did you get the covid shot did you
notice your Botox fading faster
afterwards a recent study from a group
of researchers in Israel found patients
visited their talks docs more often
after receiving their coronavirus
vaccine striking panic in the hearts and
foreheads of some users researchers
found that after receiving the Pfizer
mRNA vaccine the average time before
patients need a touch-up of the wrinkle
reducer is significantly shortened on
average the 45 participants received
Botox every 118 days prior to their
coveted shot but after the jab the
number fell to 96 days doctors say it's
likely due to an increased immune
response in the study published in the
fall in the Journal of cosmetic
Dermatology researchers concluded that
Botox injections might be less effective
following the coronavirus vaccine
although they say more research would be
needed to verify that effect it's
something doctors have told Publications
they've seen firsthand though many of
them still tell them benefits of the
covet shot coveted vaccine aside
research also shows Botox immunity can
occur on its own approximately one
percent to three percent of users
develop a Botox blocking antibody that
renders the injections practically
useless according to very well health Dr
dendy Engelman the director of
Dermatology at the Shaffer clinic in
Manhattan also notes that increased
exercise sweating saunas seam rooms hot
yoga and certain medications could all
cause neuromodulators to wear off more
rapidly for the Fox News rundown I'm
Gianna jalosi
thank you
from the Fox News podcasts Network stay
on top of the latest news and
information from Fox News listen and
download the Fox News hourly update on
your time the trending stories you need
anytime you want it listen and download
now by going to foxnewspodcasts.com
Raiden review the Fox News rundown on
Apple podcasts or wherever you listen
it's time for your Fox News commentary
Tommy Lauren what's on your mind Tick
Tock is a Chinese Communist Enterprise
disguised as a mind-numbing social media
platform I for one wish it was banned
Nationwide for obvious reasons like data
mining privacy infringements and overall
brain melting properties but thankfully
at least some universities are catching
on the University of Texas at Austin has
banned Tick Tock via campus networks
making it impossible for anyone to
access the app even on personal devices
if they're connecting via the school's
wired or wireless networks not only will
this eliminate some of the data
harvesting and privacy risks associated
with this social media platform it'll
also increase productivity and hopefully
brain function some students are angered
by this move saying the loss of Tick
Tock access inhibits their research
ability um kiddos if you're citing Tick
Tock as an academic Source you better
start reevaluating the way you research
anyway a world with less Tick Tock is a
better and a smarter world I'm Tommy
lahren and you can watch my show Tommy
laryn is fearless outkick.com
you've been listening to the Fox News
rundown and now stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com listen ad-free on
Fox News podcasts Plus on Apple podcast
and Prime members can listen to the show
ad free on Amazon music and for up to
the minute news go to foxnews.com
I'm Guy Benson join me weekdays at 3 P.M
Eastern as we break down the biggest
stories of the day with some of the
biggest newsmakers and guests listen
live on the Fox News app or get the free
podcast at guybensonshow.com